[müzik]
Evet, ABS'nin Gülüğü. Haydi bakalım. İlk
çay korakları ikinci partla devam
ediyoruz. Bir gele giriş yaptık.
Çin'den, Hint'ten bahsettik. Şimdi
Mısır, Roma. Sonra bir ufak bir yeman
hop Ali Cengiz, Ege, Meg falan
halledivereceğiz. Sonra Mezopotamya
Anadolu'yu dağılttıktan sonra yallah
İslam tarihine geçeceğiz. Şimdi arkan
aslan Mısır'a gelmeden önce Hint'te bir
şey söylemeyi unuttum. Şuraya
yazacaktım. O aklımdaydı unuttum. Değil
mi? Hindistan'ın dini yanışında da
reenkarnasyon diye bir şey var. O ne la
reenkarnasyon? O o da şu abiciğim. Beden
ölüyor değil mi? Ruh geri geliyormuş.
İşte ben bir önceki hayatımda İngiltere
kralıydım. Bir önceki hayatımda falan
kralıydım. Filan önceakkinde prenidim.
Bir önkinde prensesydim falan diye.
Onlar Hint fakirlerini kandırmak amaçlı
öyle yapmışlar. Bu sene sen şimdi böyle
burada fakur fukara yaşa da e sonraki
geldiğinde kral gelirsin deyip
kandırıyorlar. Hani bilin onu dedim ve
şimdi geldim neye? Asıl nereye? Mısır ve
Roma yukarlıkları. Bak bunlarla alakalı
sorularla geliyor. Mısır abim özgün bir
kültür oluştu. Neden lan? Herkes
birbiriyle etkileşim halinde.
Amerika'nın dünyadan haberan daha
bulunmadı. Herkes birbiriyle etkileşim
halinde birbiriyle savaşıyor, bir şey
yapıyor falan falan. Ama Mısır'da durum
öyle değil. Ne var bu Mısır'da da niye
özgün bir kültür oluştu? Bunu sordu
ÖSYM. Çünkü Mısır'ın etrafı, Mısır'ın
etrafı coğrafi konum gereği. Etrafı
doğal setlerle çevrili. Ne var la ula?
Kurban olduğum çöller, denizler var. Ne
denizi aşabiliyorsun ne çözü çölü
aşabiliyorsun. O yüzden herkes bir
millet derken bunlarda tamamen ayrı bir
ne var? Yapı var. Mesela mesela
Mısırlılar adamların mesela yazısı bile
farklı. Şey dediğin paprus dediğiniz
hieroklit dediğiniz resimli yazı var. Bu
bu ne? Kral, hükümdar işte halkına şey
yapıyor. Lütufta bulunuyor. Çinliler
yukarıdan aşağı yazıyor. Araplar sağdan
sola yazıyor. Avrupalılar soldan sağa
yazıyor. Bunlar resimle yazıyor. Herkes
de farklı giyim kuşamları. Beyaz bir tül
bir şeyle giymişler. Hepsi sürmeli böyle
hani değişik bir neleri var şeyleri var.
Ama Mısır'da gelişmiş bir medeniyet ve
Mısır'a da buraya da bir yol geliyor. Ne
geliyor? Baharat yolu gelecek ilerleyen
süreçte. Ticareti önemli. Ve Mısır'da
siyasi yönetim olarak burası nom, nomos
denilen şehir devletleri ile
yönetiliyorlar. Şimdi dersin sonunda bu
şeetlerini falan tek yazı vereceğim. Bak
abim bir yerde şehir devleti varsa orada
siyasi birlik yoktur. Bunu bileceksin.
Bak bunları soruyor. Ne yok? Siyasi
birlik yok. SB ne deme? Sosyal bilgiler
değil. Siyasi birlik yokmuş. Yani her
şehir bir devletmiş. Bulunsan düşünsen
Türkiye'de her ilin ayrı bir devlet
olduğunu, herkesin ayrı kanunu, herkesin
ayrı yasası, herkesin ayrı ne olduğunu.
O yüzden siyasi birlik yok. Başta da
despot zalim bir adam olmazsa bu şehir
devletlerinde tamam bilim bilim falan
gelişir ama başta despot zalim birisi
yoksa diye. Lakin bunlarda öyle değil.
Bunların başında Firavun denilen bir
tane zibidi var. Zibidi'nin iddiasına
bak. Ben hem kralım hem tanrıyım diyor.
Bak işte burayı sorarlar. Herif kral
yani siyasi lider aynı zamanda da tanrı.
Ulan peygamber de değil direkt tanrıyım
diyor. Anladın mı? O işte o r'sı e'sı
bilmem nesi. Ş bulmacalarda falan
geliyor ya. Bilin adam ne diyor? Bak ben
tanrı kralım diyor. İşte bu sistemin bir
adı var. Bu sistemin adı ne? Ülkeyi tek
kişi yönetiyor. Monarşi.
Monarşi. Ama hem din hem siyaset içe.
Bir da ne var? Teokrasi var. Yani burada
Mısır'da teokratik monarşi var mı? En
sona bunları da yazı vereceğim sana.
Kazanım olarak vereceğim bunları.
Anlaştık. Adam hem tanrıyım hem kralım
diyor. Monarşi var bak. Tek kişi
yönetiyor ama dine dayalı yönetiyor.
Teokratik monarşi. Benzer örneği mesela
Osmanlı'da hem padişah hem halife.
Anladın mı? Yani mesela Vatikan'da hem
Papa hem devlet başkanı gibi din devlet
beraber üretiliyorsa onun adı teokratik
monarşidir. Tek kişi üretiyorsa o zaten
direkt monarşidir. Anlaştık. Peki bu
durumda burada hukuk gelişir mi abi?
Mısır'da burada hukuk gelişmez. Neden
lan? Adam tanrı. Ağzından çıkan zaten
ne? Ağzından çıkan zaten kanundur.
Bilin. Anlaştık. Şu şehir devleti
muhabbeti aklınıza yattı mı? Daha çok
anlatacağım işte Sümerlerde,
Yunanlılarda falan diye. En sonunda da
toparlayı verdiğimde anlayacaksın. 3üncü
videonun sonuna bak. Bundan sonraki
videonun sonunda gelecek burası. Ve
Mısır'ı Mısır yapan Nil nehridir. Çölün
ortasından Nil Nehri hayat akıyor. Yani
Mısırı Mısır, Mısır Nilin armağanıdır
diyorlar. Öyle olmasaydı bu ne? Bak
yaşamak için ne lazım? Su lazım. Su
olmadan olmuyor. Sevgisiz yaşarsın.
Manitasız yaşarsın. Eksi Instagram'dan
stoklamadan yaşarsın ama su olmadan
yaşayamazsın. Yavru kurdum benim.
Anlaştık ha. İlla ne olacak? Su olacak.
İşte Mısır'a hayat veren Nildir. Ama bu
Nilak.
Bir zaman oluyor şaldır güldür. Ne var
ne yok. Hadi hurra kabala karpuz akıyor
gidiyor. Bir zaman geliyor böyle ak mi
akmeyen mi giden mi bir böyle uçukla
yaşıyor muşklaşıyor. Bir hale geliyor
değil mi? Mesela Mısır'da yaşıyoruz.
Benim evlatlarımsın. Geldik baktık o
ekinler dize kadar. Haydi yavrum yarın
buraya dedik ki şey yapalım hasat edelim
dedik. Evimize gittik yattık. Sabah bir
geldik anam anam anam anam anam nillehri
taşmış. Bizim tarla takka ekin ürün
hepsi sular altında kalmış. Çöktük anam
anam anam anam anam diye ağlarkene bir
şeyi fark ettik. Neyi? Gökyüzüne
kaldırdım kafayı bir baktım. Ulan yıldız
sende bir hinlik cinlik sende bir
yükseklik var. Tamam mı? Sen ne zaman
oraya gelsen bu Nil böyle kuduruyor. Sen
ne zaman o yıldız bu tarafa doğru gitsen
bu Nil böyle manışıklaşıyor dedi. Herif
işi gücü bıraktı. Gökyüzünü izlemeye
başladı. Gökyüzünü izledikçe de bir şeyi
fark etti. Bu gök cisimleri öyle gelişi
güzel serpiştirilmemiş. Hepsi belli bir
nizam, belli bir düzen üzere konmuş mu
ve belli zamanlarda belli yerlere
geliyor mu? Demek ki bir düzen, intizam
var mı? Herferişi gücü bıraktılar.
Gökyüzünü izlemeye başladılar ve
kaldırdılar. Neyi buldular? Güneş yılı
esaslı takvimi buldular. Hem de 365
günlük. Sadece 6 saat yanılmışlar. Peki
abim bu adamlar bunu bilim yapacağız
diye mi buldular yoksa ihtiyacın
ihtiyacın bilime olan katkısı mı?
E ihtiyaçtan dolayı işte herifler güneş
yılı esaslı neyi buldular? Takvimi
buldular. Sadece 6 saat yanıldılar. Ya
la beni zom zomlasana. Zom kamerasına
gelsene buraya. Hah anlaştık. Ben
neredeyim? Ben bu yandayım. Ben bu yana
geçince oldu. Zomz zamla. Hah tamam al.
Aha ihtiyacın bilime olan katkısıdır.
Yattı mı aklına bil. Sonra artık Nilin
bak niye buluyor bunu? Nil lehri ne
zaman daşar? Ne zaman azar? ne zaman
kudurur onu tespit edeceğiz di artık Nil
ne zaman taşıyor ediyor kılıyor bunu
biliyoruz takvimimiz var hayırlı olsun
şu an dünyanın kullandığı nedir bu
miladi takvimdir. Bu takvimi de
Romalılar alacak günümüzdeki miladi
takvim olacak. Tamam. Nilin ne zaman
taştığını biliyoruz şimdi. Ama bir
sıkıntı daha var. Nil'in etrafındaki
tarlalar o kadar değerli ki 1 milim²
toprak bile müthiş değerli. Ulan millet
birbirini öldürüyor. Çünkü o kadar şey
ki bir ekiyorsun 1000 alıyorsun. Bir
ekiyorsun 10.000 alıyorsun. Kurban
olduğum işte MEB'in kitabında ne diyor
ki ihtiyaç fazlası üretim tarımın
niceliksel dönüşümü falan diye
anlatıyor. Parayı nereden kazanacaksın?
Buradan kazanacaksın. İyi de o nil leh
kıvrım büklüm akınca o tarlaların yeri
sınırı ıvırı zıvırı değişiyor. E ne alt
edeceksin? Hadi bakalım. Hayırlı olsun
Nil. Böyle kıvrım büklüm kıvrım büklüm
geldiyse senin tarlanda önceden
burasıysa sonradan burası olduysa
şuradan hipotenüsü indirsin √3/2 şurası
bilmem ne bilmem ne üçgeninden falan
hayırlı uğurlu olsun başınızın belası
neyi buldular geometriyi buldular ya
o pi sayısının ıvını zıvını bunlarla
işlemler yapmaya başladılar hayırlı
uğurlu olsun geometriyi alana mat bir
bedava peki Peki bunlar bilim yapacağız
diye mi buldular yoksa bunlar da aynen
ihtiyacın bilime olan katkısı mı? Allah
belanızı versin. Tarla takkayı
paylaşacağız diye. Yok geometriydi, yok
hipotenüstü, yok indir dikiydi, yok
√3/2'ydi, yok ne bilen neyin karşısı, ne
bile neydi burada özel üçgen varıdı. Bir
de üstüne mat bir tarla takka
paylaşacağız diye bunların boyu bosu
devrilsin bu mısırlıların. Al başımızın
belası ben gibi tarihçe sorulur mu lan
bunlar? Al herifler neyi buldular?
geometrii, matematiği buldular. Matemat
bir işlemleri buldular. Anlaştık. Bilin.
Beraberinde bir de bunlar da değişik de
bir ahiret inancı var. Bunlarda da
benzer reenkarnasyonun bir şeyi var.
Bunlarda da nasıl? Bunlarda da beden
ölüyor fakat ruh geriye gelirmiş. İyi de
ruh geriye geldiğinde ona ne lazım? Ona
bir beden lazım. Değil mi? İşte bunlar
ölülerini mumyaladılar.
Mumyalama işleri başladı. Anlaştık ya.
Efendim? Bu da var ya müthiş bir tıp ve
eczacılık bilgisi. Nasıl? Adam öldüğünde
herkese değil ha bu. Paran varsa
yaptırsın. O dönemde aynı. Parası olan
yaptırır. Parası olmayan gömün gitsin.
Tamam. Bunları abiciğim şuradaki dikiş
izinden şuradan şöyle kabak diyip
ortadan ikiye bölüyorlar. İç
organlarının tamamını çıkarıyorlar. Özel
sıvıların olduğu kavanozlara koyuyorlar.
Daha işte bundan 20 30 yıl kadar önce
Mısır'da tutan komonun mu ne bir şeyin
mezarı bulundu. Şeyler yıkılmış.
Gavanozlar dökülmüş, devrilmiş,
kırılmış. Ama bir tane kavanozdan
herifin midesi çıktı. Mideyi çıkarmışlar
kavanozun içine koymuşlar. İçinde bir
tane özel bir sıvıların olduğu. Tamam.
Mideye üzüm suyu verdiler. Mide üzüm
suyunu özümsedi. Yani hala yaşıyor. Hala
çalışıyor. Be adam nasıl ettiniz la? da
5.000 yıllık mide boşaltım takıltılı
olsa bu şey yapacak. Boşaltım yapacak.
Be adam nasıl yaptınız? Adamın beynini
burnundan mı çıkarıyorlarmış? Niye
diyorlarsa bozulmadan çıkarıyorlarmış.
Yani bizde kolay. Bizde beyin yok zaten.
Hani rahat çıkar alırsın da bu adamlar
nasıl yaptınız be bu? Müthiş bir tıp
bilgisi, tıp anatomi, müthiş bir
eczacılık, farmakoloji, ilaç bilimini
gerektirir mi? E gerektirir. Ondan
sonrasında adam böyle ettikten sonra
kalan vücudu 2,5 kilometre sargı beziyle
sarıyorlar. Böyle al sana mumya. Sonra
beraberinde o kralları için şeyleri için
hüküm işte firavunları için piramitler
yaptılar değil mi? O Keops, Kepren ne
bilen ne den yazı verim onu da aşağıya
yoruma. Adamlar neyi yaptılar? Piramler
o aslan başlı buraya kadar işte aslan
gerisi şey buraya kadar insan gerisi
aslan falan. Hani piramitler be adam
nasıl yaptınız lan? La çölün ortasında
sen o kadar büyük taşları nasıl buldun?
Yani o taşların boyutu Mısır'a gitmek
nasip olsun. Şey Egip'te ucuz turalı
var. Gidersiniz gezin gezin tozun gelin.
Aç kalırsınız da orası ayrı ama gidin
gezin 2ü gün en azından görün. Gözünüzle
görün. Abim o bir taş şu an senin
bulunduğun odadan daha büyük be adam
çölün ortasında sen o kadar bütün blok
taşı nereden buldun lan? Hadi buldun.
Nasıl aldın geldin? La hadi aldın
geldin. Nasıl onları üst üste koydun da
o piramit o prizma bilmem ne şekline
getirdin be adam nasıl ettin? Hala
modern bilim bunu açıklayamıyor. İçine
hiyerokliflerle döşelemişler. Bu resim
yazıları yok mu? Böyle yandan profilden
böyle al bunlar döşelemiş. Biri dedi ki
ne olacak lan dedi. İçeride dedi meşale
yakmışlardır. Meşaleyle yazmışlardır
dedi. Duvarları muvarları lazerle
taradılar. İz izi yok yani. Bir adam
nasıl ettin? Dışarıda yapıp içeride
birleştirmişlerdir dedi. Birleştirme izi
yok. E bu adamlar nasıl yaptı bunu?
Kurban olduğum ya. Değiş değişik işte
güneş içeriye vurduğunda aynalarla
dağıtıyorlarmış falan falan. Atom
enerjisini biliyorlarmış. Doğru dünya
işte daha ileri bir uygarlık gelmiş
anlatmış falan diye ama burada soru
işaretleri çok fazla. Hala modern bilim
açıklayamıyor bunları. Anladın? bilim
kurgu filmlerine şey oluyor ama burada
sanki bizim dünya böyle atıyorum işte
2000 yıl yaşıyor sonra bir deprem bir
sel bir şey oluyor sıfırdan bir daha
başlıyoruz kalan kalıyor nasıl kaldığını
biz de bilmiyoruz mesela anlaştık orada
soru işaretlerimiz eksiklerimiz çok
fazla bak mesela bak Hatay'da Maraş'ta
bir deprem oldu. E yıkıldı gitti değil
mi? E şimdi oradaki adamlar en baştan mı
başladı? Kaldığı yerden devam mı etti?
Ama bazı şeyler ne oldu? Unutuldu
mesela. Ama orada kaldı mı? Kaldı.
Yaptın mı aklını? Böyle düşünün yani
kafayı da çizmen bunları bulacağız diye
bulamazsınız. Yok izlerseniz kafa gider.
Al hiyeroktif denilen şeyler var.
Papirüs denilen kağıtlar var. Hatta şu
piramitte bir özellik daha var ya. Bizim
şey vardı. Eee
programcılarımızdan Saadettin Teksoy.
Ben bulurum ararım falan diyordu. Gitti
oralara yattı kalktı. Bozuk sütü
koyuyorsun. Ertesi gün tazesini
alıyorsun. İçerisi labirentlerle doğru
giriyorsun ölüyorsun. Bir sürü bibi
tuzağı var. bilmem ne var ve içeriye
güneş, piramidin içine güneş yılda iki
kere girermiş. Biri firavun doğduğu gün,
ikincisi tahta çıktığı gün. Be adam sen
bunu nasıl denk getirdin la? Bunlar hiç
böyle rastgele olacak işler mi yoksa
ciddi şey ister mi? Ciddi bilim, ıvır
zıvır bunları ister mi? E ister.
Anladın? Al. Dini inanıştan dolayı da
bunlar gelişti mi? E bunlar gelişti.
Mısırlılardan başka bileceğiniz
sonrasında Roma işgaline girdiler ama
Mısırlılardan bileceğiniz bir olay daha
var. Ne var? Kadeş antlaşması var. Kadeş
antlaşması
tarihte bilinen ilk anlaşma diye geçiyor
ama artık modern tarih biliyor ki
bunların öncesinde de anlaşmalar var.
Daha henüz bulunmadı, çıkmadı. Daha şeye
tarihe kabul edilmedi. Ne bu Kadeş
anlaşması? Mısırlılarla Hititliler
Suriye toprakları için ne varsa o
Suriye'de kurban olduğum o zaman Suriye
toprakları için 16 yıl savaştılar fakat
galip yok. 16 yılın sonunda ikisi birden
yıkıldı gitti. İlerleyen süreçte
anlaştık. Meşhur Kleopatraları var.
Romanya şeyli imparatoruyla aşk yaşıyor
falan. Bilin. Mısır'da özgün bir kültür
olduğunu bilin ve şu şehir devleti nomos
şu firavun tanrı kral teokrasi burayı
bilin benim çetli kaldırıp da
piramitleri kim yaptı falan diye de
uğraşmayın. Anlaştık ha. Beraberinde
zomla beni Erdem 3. yıldım. Kimi de
hallettik?
Mısırı da hallettik. Geniş açıya gel.
Mısır'ı da hallettik. Tamam. Roma'ya da
attım şimdiden daha anlatmadan. Ahan da
şimdi sırada kim var? Ormanyalılar var
değil mi? Roma. Roma. Gel en sona Zomzom
kamerasına gel. Hah. Roma'ya. Ne o? İlk
çağda sınırları en geniş olanlarından
birisi. Ha bu mudur yoksa şey midir?
Helen midir bilinmez. Ama bunların da
ciddi bir genişliği var. O coğrafyaya
hükmetmişler. Akdeniz havzasına
egemenler bak hani Osmanlı İmparatorlu
haritası gözünün önüne gelsin. Tamam mı?
Akdeniz'e kıyısı olan nere varsa
komplecene hepsini almışlar. Afrika'yı,
Anadolu'yu, işte şeyi eee Avrupa'yı,
yukarıyı her yerleri almışlar.
Dolayısıyla oralarda ne olduysa, ne
bittiyse anında başkent Roma'ya gelir
mi? Gelir. Anlaştık. Aha. Kültür
etkileşim fazla mı? Fazla. Nereden
bileceğiz? Mesela takvimi Mısırlılar
buldu. Güneş yılı esaslı takvimi
Romalılar aldı. Papa Gregorien zamanında
bir ayar çaktılar. miladi takvim olduu
günümüze kadar geldi. Mesela alfabeyi
Fenikeliler buldu. E Akdeniz'de işte
günümüzdeki Lübnan, Filistin o
coğrafyada alfabeyi bunlar buldu. Eee
Romalılar aldı. Günümüzdeki Latin
alfabesi oldu. Bütün dünyada kullanıyor
mu? E kullanıyor. Aklina yattı mı?
Anlayabildin mi? H mı? Tamam. Bak nokta
atışı. beraberinde ilk çağda her yerde
olduğu gibi tarım, ticaret, hayvancılık
hepsi var mı? Hepsi var. İpek Yolu
geliyor bunlara. Sağdan soldan bir
şeyler almaya çalışıyorlar. Her şeylere
konmuşlar. Bütün hepsinde vergi alıyor
mu? Alıyor. Ama burada da sınıflı bir
toplum yapısı var. Halk bölünmüş.
Patric, Pilep, yanaşma, köle diye. İşte
patrici ve pilepler bunlar asiller.
Birinin yönetme hakkı var, birinin
yönetme hakkı yok. Yanaşma işte yılık
gibi günümüzde oraya yanaşmış, oraya
yanaşmış, ortada yanaşma diye kalmış.
Köle her zaman köle. Hiçbir hakkı yok.
La hepiniz dediniz. Spartak dizisini
izlemezsin. Yaş tutmuyor o diziye.
Hepiniz dediniz, gördünüz, biliyorsunuz
yani. Hani al ama bir yerde, bir yerde
işte bunu sorarlar. Patric ile PEP
arasında. Patric ile Plep arasında. Bunu
geçen senelerde sordu AYT sınavında 2025
sorusu olması lazım. Tamam. Eğer bunlar
arasında bir iç çatışma varsa,
ülke içinde iç çatışma varsa fetihler
bir müddet durur. Fetihler durur ama iç
çatışma bir şeyi geliştirir. Neyi
geliştirir? Hukuk gelişti. Nasıl bunlar?
ABciğim patricinin hakkı budur, budur,
budur. Pleb'in hakkı budur, budur,
budur. Yanaşmanın hakkı budur. Kölenin
hiçbir hakkı yoktur diye 12 tane
levhaya bunları yazdılar ve 12 levha
kanunları günümüz hukukunun da temelini
oluşturuyor mu? İşte bunu 2025 yılında
AYT sınavında sordular. Günümüz
hukukunun temeli. Ey videoyu izleyen
eşit ağırlıkçı kardeşim, sayısaldan eşit
ağırlığa geçecek. Hukuk yazacak
kardeşim. Hukuk fakültesine gittiğinizde
ilk gün ilk dersiniz size bu
anlatılacak. Anlaştık. O patriep
kulağınızda kalsın. Bilin. Beraberinde
bak hukuklarından bahsettik. Sonra
yönetim anlayışı. Cins. Bunlar cins.
Normalde bir devletin gelişimi şöyle
olur. Bir devlet krallık olarak başlar.
Sonra imparatorluğa geçer. Sonra
cumhuriyete geçer. Değil mi? Bunlar da
öyle değil ki. Bunlar krallıktan
cumhuriyete geçtiler. La havle ve la
kuvvete. La dünyada yok. Bunlar da var.
Tamam. İşte senatolar,
ne bileyim konsüller
bunlar ortaya çıktı. Halk böyle seçimle
bir şeylerle yöneten yönetenler böyle
şey var. Demokrasi cumhuriyet ilan
etmişler. Anlaştık. Sonra Cüllü Sezar
onlarla beraber niye döndüler gene lan?
Dediler mal mısınız lan? Dünyanın her
yerinde ne var? İmparatorluk var. Nerede
görmüşsen cumhuriyet dediler. Hop
imparatorluk meselesine geri döndüler.
Anlaştık. Yönetim anlayışları da budur.
Bu kadar basit monarşi var mı? Var.
Monarşi var. Bunların dini inanışları da
mesela Romalılarda pagan, politeist çok
ne ararsan var. Dağdaş her şeye tapmış.
Bunlardan açtık. Sonradan ne gelecek?
Hristiyanlık dinine geçecekler ama çok
sonraları da geçecekler. Tamam. bilin.
Sonra Roma'nın lejonları askeri yapıda
anlatıyor mesela bunları da. O Roma'nın
eee savaşçıları var. İşte kalkanları,
miferleri, kısap tüketikleri, o
kılıçları falanla ciddi düzenli
birlikler. Hemen birleştikleri zaman da
mesela kaplumbağa gibi ne alıyorlar?
Şeker alıyorlar. Nasıl durduracaksın
onları? Hu hu deyip adamlar koşturuyor
ve beraberinde gladiatör arena hakikaten
var. Spartak üst düzü şey filmi gerçek
ha. Bilin yani hani. Ama köleler
eziliyorlardı. İsyanetler sonuç hepsi
öldürüldü. Bilin. Askeri olarak güçlüler
bilin. Sonra ilerleyen süreçte kavimler
göçüyle Roma İmparatorluğu orta yerinden
ikiye ayrıldı. Tamam. İkiye ayrıldı. Bu
396'lı 390'lı yıllarda barbar kavimler
Batı Roma İmparatorluğu'nu yıktı ve öbür
tarafta bir de ne var? Doğu Roma
dediğimiz yer var. Doğu Roma. Buranın
özel bir adı da var. Ne o? Bizans. Hangi
Bizans? Kötü kadın Bizans. Hah. Değil
mi? Bizans'a da kim son verdi? 1453'te
yavrum benim be. İstanbul'un fethiyle
Fatih Sultan Mehmet. Biz son verdik. Çağ
attı. Çağı kapattık. Çağ açtık. Orta Çağ
kapandı. Ne başladı? Yeni çağ başladı.
Ve Roma İmparatorluğu yaklaşık 2000
yıllık bir imparatorluktu. Etkileşim çok
fazla olur mu? Olur. Mesela Bizans'tan
Osmanlı etkilenmiş midir? Evet
etkilendi. İlk etapta daha Osmanlı küçük
daha abi. Osmangazi Orhangazi 1. B
zamanında daha küçüğüüz. Bizans
uygulamalarından etkilendik. Bak
etkileşim karşılıklı olur. Ben onları
etkilerim. Onlar beni etkiler. Bunlar
adamlar yerleşik vergi mergi konusunda
bunlar daha iyilerdir. Anlaştık bilin.
Sonra işte
Hz. İsan'ın ortaya çıkmasıyla da
Hristiyanlık dinine geçtiler mi?
Geçtiler. Tamam. Sonrasında da hepten
dağıldılar, gittiler. Dedim Roma'dan da
şu 12 levha kanunları bunları bilin.
Benim chat bak ben burayı anlatırım,
döşelerim, doldururum. Gerek yok
bilmenize. Tamam. Roma'yı da hallettik.
Şimdi hemen şurayı bir sileyim. Ege,
İran, Helen, Akdeniz onlardan
bahsedivereyim. Orayı da bitirelim.
Tamam. Mezotami Anadolu soru gelirse
zaten ya Çin Hit Mısır'dan nokta atışı
dediğim yerler oraları sorar ya.
Mısır'ın şehir devletleri nomz nokta
atışı bitti. Tık işaretler geçersin.
Bana ne Mısır krallarından,
firavunlarından say desen ben kendim
bilmiyorum ki sana anlatayım sayım
direkt de duymuyorum yani. Hani anlaştık
boğulma boş ayrıntıda. Oraya ne diyelim?
Şuraları deşeleyelim sonra İslam
tarihine geçeriz. Hadi bakalım hemen
bana bir 10 saniye müsaade şurayı bir
siliverip hop yeni tahtaya geçiyorum.
Şöyle döne döne bir çıkayım. Döne döne
geleyim. Döne döne
>> döne [müzik] döne döne yar geliyor
yavrum. Güle güle güle. Geldim ben gene.
Hadi ulan kafam döndü ya lan. Bu saatten
sonra dönmek de bize şey gelmiyor ha.
Şimdi bak. Hah arkan Ayaslan dinle.
Şimdi Roma'yı da hallettik. Ege'yi de
halletmedik. Şimdi Ege ile kalanlarını
halledivereceğim. Oradan nereye
geçeceğim? Mezopotamya Anadolu buraya
geçeceğiz. Arkan Yaslan dinle. Ege
uygarlıkları. Giritler, Akalar, Mikel ve
Yunanlılar olmak üzere üç taneler.
Tamam. Şimdi bunlardan bileceğin olay
bunlar şehir devletleri şeklinde
örgütlenmişlerdir. Anlaştık. Şehir
devletleri. Yani bu şehir devletini
gördüğünde şunu bileceksin. Siyasi
birlik yok, merkezi otorite yok. Başta
despot zalim bir adam yoksa bilim
demokrasi gelişir diyeceksin. Her şehir
bir devletmiş. Ama bu Yunanlılar, bu
Giritler, Akallar, Miklilerin, bunların
bulundukları bölgede tarım sınırlı. E
hayvancılıkta bir yere kadar bunlar
neyle uğraştılar? Kolonicilik ile
uğraştılar. Aha. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun.
Kolonicilik, kolonyalizm,
müstemlekecilik
dediğin olay ne la? Bildiğin
sömürgecilik. İlk haliyle böyle başladı.
Bunlar ne yaptılar? Batı Anadolu
sahillerine geldiler. O bölgedeki o
Gedizin Mendesinin suladığı o verimli
topraklardaki ürünleri çöktüler,
aldılar, memleketlerine götürdüler. İşte
bunun adı neymiş? Kolonicilikmiş,
müstemlekecilikmiş,
kolonyalizm.
Sonra sen bunu ne diye öğrendin?
Sömürgecilik, emperyalizm diye öğrendin.
Yani sömürgeciliğin ilk hali neymiş?
Kolonicilikmiş. Bitti. Bunun ileride
yeri gelecek gene değinivereceğim
buraya. Tamam. Ve bu Giritler, akalar
falan bunlar şehirlerinin etrafını
surlarla çevirmediler. Neden? ÖSYM bunu
96 yılında sormuş. Daha sen yoksun
doğmadında. Niye? Çünkü bunlar bir ada.
E adaya neyle gidersin? Yüzerek
gidemeyeceğine göre donanmayla
geleceksin değil mi? E bunların çok
güçlü donanması var. Herifler
kendilerine o kadar güveniyorlar ki
bizim bu memlekete bunlar gelemez.
Donanmalarına gelemez deyip şehrin
etrafını surla çevirmemişler.
Özgüvene bak. Anladın mı? Mevzuyu
beraberinde bunlar taş oymacılığında
ileriler. Neden? E bulundukları bölge
kayalık abim. Dağlık bölge. Herifler
dağı oya oya oya oya oya oya Knosos
sarayınııı yaptılar. Adanın ortasına ve
bak benzerini biliyorsun. Nereden
biliyorsun mesela? Nereden biliyorsun?
Hani Trabzon'da Sümele Manastırı yok mu
lan? Dağın ortasını oyup adamlar şey
yapmış. Yüstenin efendisindeki cüceler
gibi. Kurban olduğum oymuş oymuş oymuş
oymuş. Ne yapmışlar? Saray yapmışlar.
Taş oymacılığı, ileriler. Beraberinde
çok tanrı, politeist dediğiniz olay.
Buldukları, tutukları dağını her şeye
inanmışlar. Pagan inanışları var. Doğru
dünya ne var? İnanış var. Bu
Giritlilerden şu adaların etrafını
sulara çevirmiyorlar. Neden? Güçlü
donanmaları var. Yorum sorusu olarak
gelir. Başka bir şey bilmeye gerek yok.
Yoksa ayrıntısına inmeyeceğim. Yok
dorlar, morlar, bilmem kimler falan.
Bize ne kurban olduğum geç. Yunan ise
aha karşınıza gelir. Bunlar polis
denilen şehir devletleri yönetildiler.
Bak Mısırlılarda nomostu. Yunanlılarda
polis. İşte Efes polis, Foçopolis,
Indianapolis, Metropolis gibi neler var?
Şehir devletleri var. Şehir
devletlerinde aynı yorumu olacak. Siyasi
birlik yok, merkezi otorite yok. Başta
despot zalim bir adam yoksa da bilim
gelişir diyeceksin. Bitti. Bu şehir
devletlerini en sonda bir daha toparlayı
vereceğim sana. Tamam. Ve bunlar da gene
Yunanistan'da dağlık bölge, tarım az,
tarım sınırlı. Bunlar da neyle
uğraştılar? Kolonicilikle. Yani
günümüzdeki neye geliyor? Sömürgeciliğe
geliyor. Beraberinde sınıf ayrımı ilk
çağda zaten her yerde var. Kurban
olduğumun olmadığı bir yer var mı? Yok.
beraberinde bunlar da çok tanrılı ama bu
Yunan tanrılarının bunlar tanrılarını
insan suretinde düşünmüşler. Mesela
Zeus, Apollo, Artemis, ne bileyim işte
neydi o Poseydon üç mızraklı öbürküsü
neydi? Yeraltı tanrısı. Eee, Heres, eee,
Hades. Had ha gibi mesela tanrılarını
insan suret, adam buraya kadar, insan
buradan sonrası at mesela değil mi? O
yüzden onları onurlandırmak için
heykellerini yapmışlar. Vardır ya hep
böyle
bildin mi? A Zeus heykeli böyle elinde
şimşekler, yıldırımlar falan böyle kaslı
kaslı çizerler ya. Aha bunları yapmışlar
ve o tanrıların bak heykelcilik böyle
gelişiyor. Tanrısını ne gibi düşünmüş?
İnsan suretini düşünmüş. İnanışları
sanatını etkilemiş mi? Etkilemiş. böyle
yorum sorularıyla gelirler ve
beraberinde Olympos Dağında Atana'dan
böyle gökkuşağıyla gidersin Olympos
Dağına onların biraz benim bunlara
merakım var. Biraz okuduydum,
araştırdıydım bunları bilin. Aha Olympos
doğunda tanrılarını onurlandırmak
amacıyla Zomzom kamerasına gelsene ya.
Gel şu Zomzom kamerasına.
Tanrılarını onurlandırmak amacıyla
olimpiyatlar düzenlediler. Oradaki
yapılan yarışmalarda birincilik bir
şeylik kazananlara ne verdiler? ödüller
verdiler. İşte ilk olimpiyatlar da böyle
başladı mı? Müthiş bir kültürelim olur
mu? Her yerlerden gelirler mi? Gelirler.
Şu an olimpiyatlarda dünyanın her ülkesi
hemen hemen katılıyor mu? Katılıyor.
Aklın hayattı mı? Tab bak. En başları
burası. Kültürel etkileşim. Bununla
alakalı sorularla gelirler. Beraberinde
Demos Kratos. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun.
Demos Kratos. Kratos deyince bizim God
of War değil la o. Kratos o ayrı. O
Demos Kratos halk yönetimi. Sen ne diye
biliyorsun bunu? Demokrasi
diyebiliyorsun. Kurban olduğum
demokrasi. Al burada Yunan'dan çıkacak.
Niye? E şehir devleti, birlik yok,
otorite yok, özgür düşünce var. Başının
belası bilim adamlarının alayı
buralardan çıkma işte. Anlaştık. Aha
bilin. Ve bunların kanun koyucuları var.
Mesela Drakon bu tiranlığa son veriyor.
Sonra Solon 400'ler meclisi. Kristenes
500'ler meclisini kuruyor. Bak meclis
bir yerde meclis varsa
meclis yani kralın yöneticinin yanında
birileri daha varsa onun egemenliğini
sınırlandırır mı? Evet sınırlandırır.
Aklına yattı mı? Anlayabildin mi? Yunan
meselesi hala Yunanistan'da da
duruyorlar değil mi? Gel orta kameraya
gel. Bir de Zombla bakalım. Zomb
kamerasına gel. Şuraya alıyorsa öyle
anlatım. Tamam iyi alıyormuş. Yunanlılar
böyle Anadolu'yu sömürdüler. Onlar da
zaten gelen giden bizi sömürüyor.
Alıştık kurban olduğum. Sonra Ege'yi de
bitirdik. İran uygarlıklarından. Hah.
İran'ın üç uygarlığını bileceksin. Met,
Pers ve Sasani olmak üzere. İşte Metler
en eskileri diye biliniyor ama daha çok
ayrıntı bilgi var mı? Gerek yok burada
bilmene. Tamam. Sasanileri de İslam
tarihinde falan çok göreceksiniz orayı.
Ama asıl bunların kimler var? Persler
var. Üf. Manyak mı? Manyak. Bunların
başkent perso, polis. Hoppa. Bak hiç
başkent maşkent demediydim. Şimdi
bunların neyi var? Başkent var. Bu
Persler kafayı neyle bozdular? Merkezi
otoritenin korunması. Eğer bir adamın
başkenti varsa merkez otoritesi de
sağlam mıdır? Evet. Sağlamdır. Yattı
aklına bilin. Ama bunlar başkent
Persapolis ciddi savaşçılar. Dünyanın
çoğuna egemen oldular, hükmettiler. Ama
Anadolu'nu baştan aşağı işgal ettiler.
Anadolu'nun bizim Muş'tan bir girdiler.
T İzmir'den karşıya Yunanistan'a kadar
gittiler. Değil mi? Anadolu'yu işgal
ettiler. Fakat kendi kültürlerini
Anadolu'da yayadılar. Kendileri de
nereden etkilendiler? Anadolu
kültüründen etkilendiler. Niye? Niye?
Normalde sen çöktüğün, işgal ettiğin bir
yere kendi kültürünü kakalamaz mısın?
Kakalarsın. E bunlar niye yapamadı?
Şundan dolayı yapamadı. Çünkü Anadolu
kültürü daha gelişmiş, daha modern bir
kültüre sahipti ama bunlar manyak
savaşçılardı. Tamam. Bilin. Anadolu'dan
etkilendiler. Başkentlerde mesela bak
Persopolis gördün. O polisi oradan alıp
kendi başkentlerine de koymuşlar. bil
ülkeyi satraplık denilen eyaletlere
böldüler. Eğer ülkeyi eyaletlere
bölüyorsan sınırların genişlemiştir.
Yönetimi de kolaylaştırmak
istiyorsundur. Başına da satrap denilen
adamları geçirdiler. Satrap ne? Vali.
Tamam. Ben mesela İran şahıyım. Tamam.
Anadolu'yu fethettim. Anadolu Isparta
bölgesine seni gönderdim. Satrap vali
diye. Değil mi? Ama sana güvenmiyorum.
Niye? Ya ü kat edersen ya vergiyi 5 alıp
işte birine gönderip dördünün üstüne
atarsan ne bileceksin? Otoriteyi korumak
için şah gözü gönderdi. Ajan casus.
Bunun kim olduğunu kimse bilmiyor.
Tamam. Bu adam gördüğünü, duyduğunu,
gördüğünü bıt bıt bıt bıt bıt nereye
yetiştiriyor? Merkeze yetiştiriyor.
Sonra ondan bayrı bir adam daha
gönderiyor. Şah kulağı. Bu da duyduğunu
bıt bıt bıt nereye [kahkaha]
yetiştiriyor? Merkeze yetiştiriyor. İşte
bunların hepsini niye yapıyor? merkezi,
otoriteyi korumak için yapıyor. Ülkeyi
eyaletlere gönderirsen, gönderi eyaletin
başına işte ülkeyi eyaletlere bölersen,
eyaletlerin başına vali gönderirsen,
valiyi denetleyecek adamlar gönderirsen
bunlar hep ne içindir? Merkezi otoriteyi
korumak içindir. Tarihte bilinen ilk
teşkilatlı posta işlerini bunlar kurmuş.
Yol yapımına önem vermişler. Ve bunların
hepsi neyle alakalıdır? Merkezi
otoritenin korunmasıyla alakalı. Hocam
ne alaka? Yol yapım postş ne alaka?
Kurban olduğumun ya. Hadi ülkeyi eet
bölmeyi, vali mal göndermeyi anladık da
bunlar ne alaka? Düşün başkent Ankara
Isparta'da isyan çıktı. Nereden haberin
olacak? Post teşkilatı. Uçurdular haberi
değil mi? Peki yol yapımının ne alakası
var? Hadi bu postadan haber aldık. Hadi
yolun ne alakası var? O da şu yol
meselesid ab. Bak buraya dikkatli dinle.
Demir yolları, karayolları yaptım değil
mi? Merkezden doldurursun orduları o
yoldaki şeylere. Tamam mı? gönderin
gelirler. İsyanı bastırırlar.
Dolayısıyla ülkenin eyaletlere ayrılması
böyle işte başlarına vali yöneticiler
gönderilmesi hep neyle alakalıdır?
Merkezi otoritenin korunmasıyla ve
ÖSYM'nin şimdiye kadar yaptığı
sınavların tamam mı? En çok cevap olarak
gelen iki şey var. Birincisi Merkez
Ortanın korunması. Şıklarda varsa
işaretle gitsin. Tamam mı? Çünkü bir
devlet bir şey yapıyorsa niye yapıyor?
Keyfinden değil ki. otoritesini korumak
için yapıyor. Kapiş bilin. Tamam. Nokta
atışı. İkincisi ise egemenlik
anlayışıdır. Bu ikisini çok sorar.
Şıklarda bunlar varsa kesin cevap
bunlardan biridir. Abi tavsiyesi. Ve bu
İranlıların da Zerdüş denilen bir
inanışı var. Mecusi ateşe tapıyorlar.
Anlaştık. Ama şu İranlı Persler
Anadolu'yu baştan aşağı işgal ettiler.
Anadolu bitti. Nereye geçtiler? Karşı
kıyıya. Yunanistan'a geçtiler. Orada 300
Spartalıyla termopili denilen bir yerde
savaş yaptılar kral Leonidas. O hikaye
gerçektir. 300 Spartalı o bölgedeki işte
milyonluk pers ordusunun üz binlerce
kişinin oluşturduğu Pers ordusunu dar
bir geçitte durdurmayı başardılar. Ama 3
gün 4 gün. Ondan sonrasında bütün ordu
hop arkalardan dolandı geldi. Bunların
içinden geçtiler. Anlaştık. Hah. Bilin
dedim. 300 Spartalı bakabilirsiniz
filmine. Tamam. Aha İran meselesi bu.
Sasani'yi ilerleyen süreçte
anlatıvereceğim. Tamam. O da İran'da
olduğunu bilin. Sonra kim var? Helen.
Hah. Sırasıyla geliyorum. Helen. En çok
sorulanlardan birisi de budur. Kim bu?
Makedonlu Filip'in oğlu. Tarih
öğretmenliği alan sınav sorusu. The
great Alexander. Siz ne diyebiliyorsunuz
onu? Büyük İskender diyebiliyorsunuz ama
boy 1.50. Aç bak Google'dan. Kısa boylu.
Kısa boyluyla boyun da bu da takıntılı.
Bu Büyük İskender Yunan'ın torunu. İyi
de Yunan'nın torunu da Büyük İskender'in
dedesi. Yunanlıların içinden kim geçti?
Persler geçti, değil mi? Büyük İskender
Makedonya'dan bir harekat başlattı. T
nereye kadar gitti?
T Hindistan'a kadar gitti. Orada fil de
depor. Öyle mi ölüyor? Ne bir şey öyle
ölüyor. Tamam. Adam farkına varmadan
doğu kültürüyle batı kültürünü
sentezledi, birleşti. Aradan bir ne
çıktı? Hellenizm, Hellas çıktı. İşte ilk
çağın en gelişmiş kültürü hangisidir?
Hellenizm, Hellast'tır. Avrupa atası
olarak kimi görür? Yunan'ı görür. Ta
buradan geliyor işte o olay. Anlaştık.
Hellenizm, hellas, hellenistik dönem ve
bak ilerleyen süreçte bu hellizm
başınızın belası Aristoteles, Pisagor,
Tuguditides, Pilates, Prilates yok lan
hepsi bunlardan çıkmıştı. Yunanlılar,
bunlar torun zaten dede torun oralardan
gelmişler. Anlaştık bilin. Ama işte
hatta bu Makedonlu Filip'in oğlu Büyük
İskender giderken batıdan bilim
adamlarını da yanında götürüyor. Bunu
böyle yorum sorusu olarak sordular.
oradan oradaki bilim adamlarını batıdan,
doğudan batıya, batıdan doğuya
gönderiyor. İşte doğuyla batı birleşti.
Sentez ne çıktı? Hellenizm kültürü
çıktı. Anlaştık. Nokta atışı bilgi
bilin. Sonra Büyük İskender oralarda
öldü, öldürüldü, bir şeyler oldu, kaldı
gitti. Sonra çok geniş bir sınıra
hükmediyordu. Toprakları komutanları
arasında bölündü. Antigonit diye bir
komutanı Balkan topraklarına kondu.
Pitolomei diye bir komutanı Mısır
topraklarına kondu. Ama beni
ilgilendiren hangisi? Selefos diye bir
komutanı Anadolu topraklarının üzerine
kondu. Anadolu'da da mesela yeni
yerleşim yerleri oluşturulu. Mesela
Bitinya.
Bitinya bak. Bitinya değil. Bitinya.
Britanya değil. Orası İngiltere. O ayrı.
Tamam. Bitinya neresi? Bizim Kuzey
Marmara'nın olduğu yer işte. E Kocaeli
şey Osmanlı'nın o kurulduğu coğrafya
Bitinya olarak geçiyor. Pontus Karadeniz
bölgesinin adı. Ta bizden 2000 yıl
öncesinden beri oranın adı Pontustu.
Kapadokya ürgüp Göreme. Orta Anadolu'nun
adı güzel atlar diyarı değil mi? Klikya
Adana Urfa, Adana civarı Klikya. Hani
cemiyet var ya Klikyalar diye. Ta
buradan kalma. Milletlerin öncesi bilmem
kaç bin yılından kalma bunlar. Anlaştık
ama Bergama İzmir sahilleri işte orası
önemli. Anlaştık. 200.000 ciltlik bir ne
var burada? Kütüphane var. Üf.
Beraberinde Asklopien sağlık ocağı var.
Hepiniz biliyorsunuz.
Herodot'u bildiniz mi? A buralarda şey
Erodot diyorum. O tarihçi bizim ehbap.
Tamam mı? Hipokrat. Hipokrat. Tıpçı. A
buralardan çıkma işte ne gelişti? Bilim
gelişti. Tamam. Özgür düşünce ortamı
varsa otomatikman ne gelişir? bilim
gelişir. Ve son olarak Doğu Akdeniz'deki
iki uygarlığım. İran'ı hallettim,
Helen'i hallettim, Doğu Akdeniz'i
hallettim. Amerika'dan zaten
bahsetmiyoruz. Maya, Toltek, Astek,
inkap dedik, geçtik. Tamam. Türk'ten
ayrıca anlatacağız. Mesotam Anadolu ama
şu önce Doğu Akdeniz'i bir halledelim.
Doğu Akdeniz'de iki uygarlığımız var.
Biri Fenikeliler, biri İbraniler. Ha bu
Fenikelilerde Finike değil. O bizim
Antalya, Kumbuca, Finike ora değil.
Fenikeliler. Dağlık bir bölge. Lübnan
bölgesi. Günümüzdeki Filistin'in olduğu
coğrafya. E tarım sınırlı. Bunlar da
neyle uğraştılar? Bunlar da
kolonicilikle uğraştılar. İlk can en
kolay abim. Güçlü gelir zayıf kafasına
vurur. Zayıfın her şeyini alsana
kolonicilik. İşte bildiğin günümüzdeki
sömürgecilik. Ama Fenike kolonileri ile
Yunan kolonileri karşılaştırmalı
sorulur. Nasıl? Fenike kolonileri kalıcı
olmamıştır. Kalıcı değil. Ama Yunan
kolonileri Yunan kolonileri kalıcı
olmuştur. Neden diye sordu ÖSYM. şundan
dolayı. Çünkü fenikeller abim bunlar
sömürgeci.
Bunlar sömürgeci. Bunlar geldiler o
koloni olarak, sömürge olarak çöktükleri
yerlerin altyapı, üst yapı, yiyecek,
içecek ne var ne yok hepsini aldılar
gittiler. Tamam. Bir daha da
uğramadılar. Ama Yunanlılar öyle değil.
Yunan kolonileri kalıcı oldu. Neden?
Çünkü Yunanlılar o kolonilerini ikinci
vatan, ikinci yurt gibi görmüş.
Yunanlılar kolon olarak çöktükleri yere
Yunanistan'da ne yeniyorsa onu
yedirmişler. Yunanistan'daki kanun neyse
onu yapmışlar. İkinci yurt vatan gibi
görünce Yunan kolonileri daha uzun
ömürlü olmuştur. Önceki yılların t 20
sene öncesinin sorularıydı bunlar işte
bilin. Ve beraberinde Fenikeller tarihte
bilinen ilk alfabeyi de bunlar yaptı. Bu
alfabeyi Romalılar aldı. Günümüzdeki
neye döndü? Latin alfabesine döndü. İlk
bunlar yapmış. Bunlar nokta atışı. Soru
aşağıdaki bilgi eşleştirmelerinden
hangisi yanlıştır? İlk alfabe, ilk para,
ilk anlaşma, ilk bilmem ne falan diye
böyle Hitit, Frik, Lidya işte Fenike
böyle verirler. Tamam. Bu şey sorusu.
AYT sorularıdır. Ve bunlar bir de cam
işlemeciliğinde ileri gitmişler. Bu cam
da neyden yapılıyor biliyor musunuz? Mu?
Plaj kumu yok mu? İnce kum. İnce kumu
bilmem kaç bin dereceye kadar çıkarırsan
kristalleşir. Ne olurmuş? Cam olurmuş.
Bu vardır. Batı Anadolu'da mesela Bodrum
o taraflara falan olur da giderseniz
eğer o şeyde Selçukta Efes'te falan cam
işlemeciliği yapıyorlar orada hemen
ısıtıyor böyle hop şek üf üfürüyor hemen
al sana. Hop yaptı verdi bitti gitti.
Soğu verdiği yanında da kristalleşiyor
cam oluyor. İşte bunlar nasıl fark
ettiler biliyor musuz mu? Koloniler
gittiler ya. Koloniler gittiler ya. E
gitti geri dönecek de. Navigasyon mu var
kurban olduğum? Nereden bilecekler?
sahilde onların geleceği o gün
dönümleri, ay dönümleri, bilmem neleri
var ya hani orada işte atıyor ki üç şey
sonra, kış sonra geleceğiz diyor mesela
değil mi? Adamlar çok büyük sahile ateş
yakıyorlarmış ki geldiklerinde uzaktan
görebilsinler ateşi diye. Sonra ateş
yanıyor da sonra bir bakıyorlar sahil
komple cam kumdan yapıldığını bilin.
Genel kültür olsun. Ve Doğu Akdeniz'in
son uygarlığı anlatacağım İbranilerdir.
İbranilerden de gelecek tek soru tipi
var. Bunlar tarihte tek tanrılı, ilahi,
semavi, kitabi dine illa tek tanrılı
demez. İlahi,
semavi
kitabi
din der. Anladık. Yani bunun hocam
manezim, budizm de ne onların kitabı
yok. Allah tarafından değil. milleten,
kendiliğinden çıkardı. Ama işte hani o
dinler var ya Musevilik, Hristiyanlık,
İslamiyet bildin mi? Tevrat beraberinde
şey eee İncil, Kur'an-ı Kerim işte
bunlardan ilki Musevilik. Tarihte tek
tanrılı, dine inanan ilk topluluk
kimdir? İbranilerdir. Musevilik
dediğiniz. Anlaştık bu din. Ama şimdi
burada Yahudiler işte bildiğiniz
Yahudiler ama bunları karıştırmayın.
Musevilik başka bir şey, Yahudilik
meselesi başka bir şeydir. Bunlar dini
millileştirdiler. Yani dediler ki işte
günümüzdeki İsrail işte katil İsrail
işte. Anladın? Bunlar dini
millileştirdiler. Dediler ki y dediler
Yahudi olunmaz.
Yahudi doğulur dediler. Dini
millileştirdikleri içinde yayılamadılar.
Ulan en eskisi bu. En az yılanı da bu. E
millileştirilsen yayılmaz. Hristiyanlık,
İslamiyet dünyanın neredeyse tamamında
ama bunlar sadece belli yerdeler. Ve
bunlar hep bunlara rabbim peygamber
gönderiyor. Peygamber kime gönderilir?
Gel orta kameraya. Peygamber kime
gönderilir? Raydan çıkmış toplumlara
gönderilir. Değil mi? Bunlar da abeciğim
şey zannediyor. Ulan Allah bizi hiç es
geçmiyor. Sağ olsun olsun. Bize hep
peygamber gönderiyor. Gönderdiği
peygamberler de kral falan filan falan
diyor. Tamam mı? Ama ilerleyen süreçte
lan kime gönderilir? Raydan çıkmış
toplum. Bunlar hiç girmemiş ki raya.
Tamam. En son peygamberlerini de
öldürdüler. Zekeriya'yı kestiler. Onu
bilmem ne ettiler. Öbürünü denize
attılar falan falan derken tamam. En son
bunlar gittikleri yerde de oldukları
yerde de huzur da vermiyor. Tarihte üç
büyük katliama uğradı bu Yahudi
meselesi. Kim onlar? İlki işte bu
Babiller.
Babil kralı hamura. Bunları kütür küt
şey yapmış. Arkasından eee bir
Romalılar. Romalılar da bunları bir
sürgüne gönderiyor. Sonra Hitler, bak
bunlar hep neye uğradılar? Şeye
uğradılar. Zulme uğradılar. Katliama
uğradılar. Bilin yani. Hani tamam niye?
Çünkü ortalığı karıştırıyorsan
sürdürürsün. Sürgüne uğrarsın bilin
dedim. İlk çağ uygarlıklarının genel
yapısı genel böyle işte bunların siyasi,
hukuki yöneten savaşçılar, askerler,
ekonomi, bilim bu yönüyle MEB kitabı.
Bunun hepsini, bu aynılarını tamam mı?
Tek tek önce devleti anlatıyor, sonra
hukuklarını anlatıyor, sonra yönetimi
anlatıyor, sonra işte bir daha bilimini
anlatıyor. Yani o yüzden bir tahtada
hepsini verdik, geçtik. Şimdi son olarak
Mesbotamya ve Anadolu'dan bahsedeceğiz.
İlk çağşimiz bitecek. İslam tarihine
geçeceğiz. Haydi sonraki ders görüşmek
üzere.